- [Instructor] Jeremiah makes 25%
of the three-point shots he attempts.
Far better than my percentage.
For warm up, Jeremiah likes to shoot
three-point shots until
he successfully makes one.
Alright, this is the telltale signs
of a geometric random variables.
How many trials do I have to take
until I get a success?
Let M be the number of
shots it takes Jeremiah
to successfully make his
first three-point shot.
Okay, so they're defining
the random variable here,
the number of shots it takes,
the number of trials it takes
until we get a successful
three-point shot.
Assume that the results of
each shot are independent.
Alright, the probability
that he makes a given shot
is not dependent on
whether he made or missed
the previous shots.
Find the probability that
Jeremiah's first successful shot
occurs on his third attempt.
So, like always, pause this video
and see if you can have a go at it.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
So, we wanna find the probability.
So, M is the number of shots it takes
until Jeremiah makes
his first successful one
and so, what they're really asking us,
find the probability
that M is equal to three,
that his first successful shot
occurs on his third attempt.
So, M is equal to three.
So, that the number of
shots it takes Jeremiah
to make his first
successful shot is three.
So, how do we do this?
Well, what's the probability
of that happening?
Well, that means he has to
miss his first two shots
and then make his third shot.
So, what's the probability of
him missing his first shot?
Well, if he has a 1/4 chance
of making his shots, he
has a 3/4 probability
of missing his shots,
so this will be 3/4,
so he misses the first shot,
times, he has to miss the second shot
and then he has to make his third shot,
so there you have it.
That's the probability.
Miss, miss, make
and so, what is this going to be?
This is equal to nine over 64ths.
So, there you have.
If you wanted to have this as a decimal,
we could get a calculator out real fast,
so this is nine divided by 64
is equal to roughly 0.14.
Approximately 0.14
or another way to think about it
is a roughly 14% chance or 14% probability
that his first successful shot
occurs in his third attempt.